unlike at the genres action movies don't
need to be filled with nuanced
performances or a water-type plot if
anything those things just get in the
way of the face-punching
all the good action movie needs is a
sky-high bullet budget some flippy kicks
and kerosene burning through its veins
from start to finish for snellie Netflix
has jammed full of underrated action
movies if you'd rather see bruised
Chin's and Oscar wins this movie roundup
will be right up your alley skin trade
Dolph Lundgren Ron Perlman Michael Jai
White and Tony Jaa sounds like a dream
action movie cast if we've ever seen one
and skin trade delivers on that promise
in spades
granted the plot is pretty flimsy it's
basically cops and robbers in Thailand
but the thrill of seeing these action
legends all in one place doesn't wear
off
Lundgren manages to keep up with the
much younger and more agile jar in some
wild action scenes and Jai White is as
always a magnetic on-screen talent come
for a talent lineup stay flee insanity
and fistfights Savage Doug Scott Adkins
has pretty much the undisputed king of
direct-to-dvd action movies these days
and savage Doug is an impressive entry
in his filmography we rarely get to see
Adkins at a period piece and even though
he mostly just beats people up he gets
to do it in different costumes as time
but beyond the unusual setting a savage
dog is still something special the movie
opens uh vatican's character digging his
way out of a shallow grave which is the
only way to start a movie like this the
film then goes back in time catching us
up to the moment of his burial and then
sending him on a brutal path of revenge
featuring some stunning fight sequences
Atkins filmography is littered with cool
action hits but savage Doug is a clear
high point bullet to the head released
in 2013
bullet to the head comes from Walter
Hill director of the 1979 cult classic
the Warriors it's pure grindhouse fun
which is exactly what a Walter Hill
action flick starring Sylvester Stallone
should be bullets fly bodies drop and
cars are blown to bits over the course
of the movie it's a great time
solidified by Jason Momoa as role as the
film's villain you don't want to miss it
Boyka undisputed Scott Adkins headline
later installments of the undisputed
series as Yuri Boyka a prison inmate who
participates in a brutal underground
fighting ring Boyka undisputed C's boy
key released from prison and fighting
professionally but the fight scenes are
just as stylish and brutal as any that
came before this in the series four
movies in undisputed as as fun as it's
ever been
bring on the next one small soldiers
children of the 90s are likely to
remember the toys are spawned from
director Joe Dante small soldiers along
with the crushing disappointment that
they didn't actually come to life and
try to blow up your house the film
itself is something of a Forgotten gem
one that's definitely made for a younger
audience but an action movie is an
action movie and this one is actually a
lot of fun small soldiers as weird campy
and features action figures go into war
with each other which for most kids was
the best toy based combat outside of toy
commander for the sega dreamcast sky
captain in the world of tomorrow in a
just world
Sky Captain and the World of Tomorrow
would have been a box-office smash and
ushered in a new era of elegant
stylistic action cinema drawing heavily
from pop cinema and comic books sky
captain is a wild rom for a steampunk
reimagining of a pre-world War two world
the titular sky captain is a charismatic
ace pilot who leads the daredevil flying
legion played by Jude Law he's joined by
reporter Polly Perkins and a brief
appearance by Angelina Jolie as the
eyepatch the royal naval officer Frankie
cook it's a great cast heading up a fun
a visually inventive action film that
deserves a far larger fun following than
it has today
officer down want to watch the craziest
movie on Netflix officer down as you
covered adapted from the comic by writer
Joe Casey and artist Chris Burnham there
shouldn't be a way to translate this
insanity from page to screen and yet the
film manages to pull it off starring kim
coates of sons of anarchy fame it's the
hyperkinetic neon thrill ride that plays
out like Judge Dredd in a fever dream
this movie has everything nuns with guns
and immortal super cop and a hidden
government conspiracy what more could
you ask for
fighting it's kind of hard to remember
the days when Channing Tatum wasn't a
megastar
but back before Magic Mike and 21 Jump
Street Tatum appeared in this little
scene gem Tatum plays the tough as nails
Shawn a hustler who discovers he's a
prodigy as a street fighter the fight
scenes are brutal no-holds-barred
Affairs that translate the intensity of
street fighting to the screen very well
fighting was never going to win any
Oscars but it's a very interesting and
often overlooked entry in a talented
actors career death sentence modern
horror master James Wan of saw insidious
and the conjuring Fame took a brief
hiatus from the genre in 2007 with the
death sentence a Kevin Bacon be a cool
that follows the tried and true
narrative of a regular man out for
revenge when his son is stabbed in a
gang initiation ritual Bacon's Nick Hume
decides to take the law into his own
hands
waging a one-man war on crime in a city
it's nothing action fans haven't seen
before
but you haven't seen this kind of film
directed by a Wiz like James Wan or with
an actor so effortlessly Gerdes kevin
bacon bacon channels nick's relentless
drive grief and rage in stunning
understated fashion throw in John
Goodman as the film's villain and you've
got yourself a good time
it may be familiar action movie
territory but sometimes that just means
it's worth the journey thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]